Mikko I wanted to see me do your costume
on when you got more why are you wearing
it you're talking into thin air Nico we
can't hear you you're speaking to
thinner oh okay just props I thought I
thought you had like an outfit or
something and I didn't understand why
why you weren't wearing it okay okay
cool okay I kind of like this outfit I
do too actually
I think it's perfect for the perfect for
the boy I'll be honest it's pretty good
it's a good app that's a good outfit
it's a good outfit he did a good job he
did a great job you have to come over
here costume it's a bit too fit it's a
good outfit yeah I'll be honest that's a
really good outfit so Nico's got a
t-shirt on which is one of one of the
worst t-shirts I've ever seen it's I'm
the Hershey's kiss I don't think it's a
kiss it's not a Hershey's kiss it's a
little it's a brown triangle with two
eyes and a smile what does it nigo it's
a piece of [ __ ] it's a poop emoji oh
okay so the t-shirt is to say I'm the
[ __ ] yeah except he's got a poop emoji
mask on yeah so he is a human excrement
is that right yeah yeah a giant pile of
[ __ ] thank you right welcome
wait and and he's holding a Wonder Bread
yeah which I would imagine would be a
loaf of bread yeah yeah so you're you're
a [ __ ] sandwich
Nico a [ __ ] low fat is tremendous and
sit down you in that chair over there
because now let's see what the way to
Anthony dressed up as yeah even though
you try to barge in yeah I don't know do
you think anything is good timing no no
he doesn't listen he panics he's just
following oh he came in here and he's
like I thought they just meant like then
well they did why would it be two
seconds yeah give me two seconds okay
sure call it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
loaf trying to walk in here what a dick
no smiles [ __ ] I mean I like him don't
get me wrong I like him right but he's a
piece of [ __ ] and he's an idiot
and he's a loose but you like him but I
like him don't get me wrong I like him
okay yeah fine
he's piece of [ __ ] okay so timing these
stupid stupid idiot experi you're kind
of a judgmental guy who likes conspiracy
theories right okay you were in a shirt
that's got it looks like you like shin
bra rock-and-roll t-shirt on yeah he's
got to - Selita to ease the other foam
it one of them looks like it's just tape
that you drew on and what sphere see oh
I see that's the conspiracies and the
other one is like a tattoo sleeves okay
so you got your arms all tatted up you
got rock-and-roll t-shirt on fliction
I'm sorry affliction bra yeah what is he
holding up I can't say ok Google calm a
piece of paper print it out and it's a
screen cap of the Google homepage just
little handshake little hand shaking
nervous he's googled the word google.com
oh I love it yeah you kinda you're kind
of coming off a guy you see you seem
like I don't know who you're supposed to
be he's like a foolish man
oh you dress like a foolish man are you
I love it now you guys should be in
costume all day oh and in carrot but if
you want oh he said conspiracy or life
yeah who killed JFK Vegas shooter mo the
big issue right yeah nobody knows the
real story just wait oh you want to go
down this road a big serious now Anthony
look at me you sure you wanna go down
this road no no
what are you doing of course I'm
Halloween costume [ __ ] you off your
glasses experience is that tape it up
it's creative these are good costume
there's very good costume I think the
guys did a great job but Roy in a [ __ ]
of [ __ ] loaf it's pretty good yeah I
would hate to be dressed up as would you
well you know somebody came in is Jim
Norton yeah yeah
they hate it too your life this is no
good
no they be like doing yeah I I know I
will you don't want to see yourself
caricatured no no gonna be accurate but
never the flattering parts no it's never
the good part of compassionate moments
like you know at the end of the day I'm
actually a really great guy no yeah yeah
it's gonna be somebody coming with their
head buzzed blinking unprepared right
right just a lot of extra forehead and
the inability to tell a funny joke why
would they say that about you
oh you pointed yourself so yeah I
appreciate that
no funny jokes I know I know I don't
know does anyone come on it's fine it's
perfect that should help you very funny
guys very funny Travis who do you think
went to the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
Halloween pageant Nico really yeah
because he's got tape on one of his arms
no he dies but here's the thing Nico is
is is is is in an instant funnier
because it's just a pile of [ __ ] and
yeah but Anthony will suffer long-term
consequences for the whole I will change
my vote if Anthony commits to the bit
the entire day Anthony's took a lot more
balls Nico's I love ya Nico's ready not
to take anything away from Nico no yeah
it took a little balls but then like the
second Troy said hey you sure you
do is good no there's a tattooed man
bullying yes
afraid Choi's a loose cannon
I kind of got nervous - I swear to god
yeah I think I don't know I think it's a
four for Anthony to be in the position
that he's been in for the past
yeah the barrel life yeah 27 years I
suppose yeah
to come out and start swinging yeah he
came out so I liked it
somebody's a compliment for uh for
Anthony here on st. Anthony's taking a
Kevin in Louisiana yes Kevin yeah I I
personally think this is a good time for
Troy to get another year suspension from
the radio that's never been suspended
yeah never a year suspension it's a bit
much so now you say you think this is a
you think this is Anthony being real or
spending choice phasers just joking we
think I say radio whenever he was banned
from I don't think that's a good idea at
all Troy I wish you wish to the office
do you think should win whoo all right
all right if you could take yourself out
of the equation but I was so stupid when
I saw you walking down at the tattoo I
still didn't know who you were no I had
no idea conspiracy I'm like oh ho
I'll give Anthony credit he's got balls
I mean his he's gonna pay for this
dearly do you think he's got more more
guts than brains in this moment I mean
he's won maybe one of the stupidest
people I've ever met my life do you find
his costume offensive I don't find it
offensive I just think he is a complete
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's maybe the stupidest
person we've ever worked with in this
show
I don't think sure I don't think so
Anthony yeah there's been a lot of dumb
people a lot of dumb people water yeah
comment I mean you know victim oh maybe
you're not that dumb
what do you think [ __ ] love Scott I mean
it looks great Halloween shapes make
[ __ ] look fake [ __ ] Thank You loaf is
very good outfit yeah that's a very good
outfit it's clever too and plus it looks
happy cuz there's a smile on the [ __ ]
and guess what what [ __ ] love smiles
every day he does she love is happy
except when he fears a bodily harm from
Troy oh no no no no no no no no he's
zero Bobby I will never touch or hurt
anybody that's good news right that's on
the up and up I don't think you need to
be on please don't be so afraid no
here's your costume you got this you got
own it bro yeah that's right Roy is not
a guy who is afraid because he's
portraying yeah yeah Troy so that's like
that's like dressing as a Superman and
then all of a sudden you take the cape
off and going on rubble plus here's the
best part you got sunglasses on so like
even if you are like yeah breaking down
inside because it's like very scary I
get it trust me get some glasses on we
can't see your eye it's all good Sam
almost got beat up by Pat Duffy he stood
there in almost I mean and what I say
almost well you kept throwing little
papers at him
yeah I was yeah I was I thought they
were gonna arrest Pat that damn I'm
gonna miss Pat Duffy yeah I mean because
I've always thought like okay if I take
one punch I'll be fine but when I looked
at him that day I was like now I might
not be fine even if it's just one punch
saw Pat was [ __ ] steaming yeah yeah
but I was I was getting a pushed along
to do that and I was like yeah [ __ ] it
you know we're doing this now yeah Rob
Rob is reminding me that that if Anthony
is really gonna commit to the bit Troy
is also a good worker that's true Wow
you know it's completely impossible for
him in you a ting I know yeah but I
would also say that Rob it's tough for
Rob to take shots when he came he made
literally no nothing he's nothing he's
got message and to come to work dressed
as Rob Rob comment I'm a grown adult
either of those things is it both
I'm a mail boy yes I'm an adult big
person hey did he get the girl again oh
no you want to know oh god yeah I found
out five minutes before you walked in oh
yeah I want to know Kenny Kenny uh
please he's coming in yeah I would like
seven some chips all right come in by
the way I've seen two too many chip
chippers and costumes on Twitter so I oh
there's a couple yeah one guy was great
I only saw one but that should by next
year that'll be a tremendous costume
industry exactly yeah that's you you
should make you should spend the next
year figuring out how you can sell cheap
costumes for next Halloween I will yeah
this year is a little soon there's only
30 episodes in but by next year it's
going to be a sensation yes it's nothing
else in my career as well text from the
boss yeah I want to hear more of Anthony
impersonating Troy so which boss done
nice Oh Donna likes Troy he's on things
Troy Sanders what do you think about
that Troy conspiracy
you don't think Donn really wants to
come on Brock because his moments where
he's like nervous about Troy then
there's moments where he's in character
he just starts to falls into it yeah I
mean you can still like Troy stare
daggers into the bed what he does is it
Troy you don't like it i its whatever
it's funny but I mean Anthony really is
one of these stupidest [ __ ] people
I've ever met in my life
no and and it's a miracle he got hired
here it really is because he's that
[ __ ] stupid it's funny honey but he's
a no choice because he cleared his
throat before he's like you know mm
here's the in the throat clears like
this is not what do you think about
Anthony Troy he's an idiot yeah [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] them fire them
it's good to [ __ ] when you eat thank
Eric tur yeah conspiracy don't break it
dude your character doing so good you
know a funny
if you just started copying everything
Troy said yeah it was I don't think
you'd like but that's but more like you
have a living breathing it's all mostly
if you're playing a role like when
Philip Seymour Hoffman was playing like
hoo-hoo-dilly playing the Capote yeah
like it might be had to look upon you to
hang out right like you know that's what
you have right he's your Truman Capote
and then it can be like yeah yeah it's a
lot
eggsy he's just little troy little throw
in ' right well story
yeah what do you think of the costumes
hot dog I still like yours the best what
am I supposed to do yeah I'm glad I
thought before I blurted out my ass so
uh so what happened i I just I don't
know why I don't normally follow the the
saga but I was just thinking what if he
could I had a mean Halloween joke know
if you saw this girl again yeah yeah I
saw her on Saturday
oh nice makeup for makeup four four four
previous mistake yeah no I didn't make
up for it
why um I don't know she was coming over
on sorry there so she kind of came over
surprised hey I'm over here and I didn't
have any of the stuff that I was
preparing for to have so why don't you
have it you'd have a with you mean
details yeah I just figured I wasn't
gonna see her this week because she
always carry them dude no he's carry
difficult that's 25 it's sad do you know
I used to carry them in in my I would
take a [ __ ] sigh Alice or a [ __ ]
viagra and like a drugged-out and you
wrap it in tinfoil you're orbit gum or
whatever comes with and you put it in
the packet I would always have a face
Jim Carrey's cialis like like old people
carry life alone yeah like they carry
nitroglycerin yeah I mean in case I felt
something for I smiled at me I'll just
put on my tongue and let it melt and
then I have one with you so you didn't
have one with you girls
she just sees you she just smiles like
oh thank you
so okay you didn't have a pill but
that's a mental
think he's a [ __ ] confidence isn't
that it is a mental thing [ __ ] so I I
went for it again because I was like
yeah well you know what last last week
is probably like a fluke or something 25
and 35 I never have sex yeah yeah don't
get lazy much sister yeah so I started
like some foreplay and kissing and all
that stuff and then she like I got her
naked and then I was I was hard the
whole time like leading up to it were
you thinking to yourself like yes yes
yes right yes yes everything is going
smooth until like I started pulling my
pants down yes as soon as i unbuckled it
it just might work yeah that's all
mental you dick is fine oh boy you got
you gotta do what work your way into it
like make you're saying I'm not gonna
[ __ ] this time yeah they don't [ __ ]
one time you matter how hard your dick
is I'm not gonna [ __ ] I'm just gonna get
it a licker that's interesting this way
you know you're not gonna [ __ ] you don't
get performance anxiety that was ready
to go yeah yeah get it pop at your mouth
a little bit and just suck it hey you
don't want to [ __ ] it bad you think you
do
and then you took your pants down and
there it's just a retreated I mean maybe
it's her oh no he's mental you nervous
she hot I think she's cute he's
good-looking yeah yeah and I mean I
think we saw a photo last time it's not
her no it's not her no you know I mean I
had it I kind of had a chance to get
laid two weeks prior with another girl
and that didn't work out for other
reasons but as I was naked then I was
rock hard I was ready to go so how come
it didn't work out that because she has
a roommate that has a crush on her and
then as soon as I was naked he kind of
just kicked the door in
cock-blocked you pick door and just turn
the light on yeah yeah yeah my dick was
out uh yeah I was ready to go so wait
don't don't don't
take all your clothes off just pull your
dick out through the hole in the zipper
it takes a lot of the pressure of the
whole act of getting nude pull your dick
out so you show suck your dick while
your pants are still on and then realize
you're not gonna just work into it a
little bit yeah that's my actual anus
yeah or where you go wear boxers and
then you can just be stripped out in
your boxers and then pull your dick out
of the fly box pulling your clothes off
is like a [ __ ] spotlight but you're
getting ready to take
think you're on stage Allah said in the
light hit you and like okay now it's
time right and you should be proud of
your body I think so I think you should
be proud of your body you should show it
off more hmm what did you do that maybe
at work you start showing your body sure
more shirtless like a belly shirt maybe
some shorter shorts mmm I don't think
it's that okay because I think you
should be proud of your body
Thanks do you wanna [ __ ] or die's just
want to blow job I want to [ __ ] okay
yeah the other girl is trying to get a
[ __ ] and I was fine and it's not cuz
you're jerking off too much no and then
IIE as soon as I got naked and I got
soft I grabbed my phone went to the
bathroom like picked up like like maybe
three clips of porn uh-huh you started
that's your porn addiction when you have
a live girl in front of you I get a
heart let me go watch images yeah it
wasn't working that no no no of course
that was it for like three or four
minutes going at it nothing and did she
there's nothing worse than when you like
your dick is bloodless liquid its it's
like a it's almost like a temperature
change like it's just blood and you're
like there's no way this is getting yeah
hard at that point I was just thinking
of excuses while I was drinking off yeah
what like what well I go what did you
end up saying yeah I went well you
didn't tell me we were coming today last
forget that have a condom and they don't
have a comment today you just kind of
condom thing yeah like why wouldn't you
bought condoms right after last time
when she didn't ask that but I was like
she said she was disappointed me they
had sex last week and I was you know
next week I'll you know I'll have
something yeah you know or you'll do it
when you want yeah okay let her know
that it's a problem that the women are
too used to say no and when they when
they don't want to they just [ __ ]
spit in their hand and they're [ __ ]
right it we can't do that yeah so stop
making excuses you don't have you don't
object to wanna [ __ ] your [ __ ] when
you want to yeah yeah just tell me what
mopping her mouth once anyone you pop in
your mouth for a couple minutes
[ __ ] to it on it what's your strategy
usually Troy cialis bro that's it
pop what in should be right as rain
right is ready bro thanks I had no I had
nothing have you ever said the race
right as rain no do you know you'll be
right as
I want to talk to aunt Anthony what you
ever said that before yeah I didn't
think so
dragon filly is not happy with Troy
what's Greg and filly got to say I guess
cry crying Troy yes four years
everything choices always can make photo
himself he seemed just always angry and
he's exhausting to begin with but he
just seems very angry and humorless at
like every point of the show and just
like the kids just doing a Halloween
costume just laugh at them listen Frank
I understand why you'd say that yes but
if Sam or Jim goof on me I'll have a
sense of humor about it
this little [ __ ] turd around I have
no sense of humor this guy can't even do
his job correctly can't do anything so
it's like thanks I did want to add in
just for the sake of the argument okay
Craig Anthony's got the free I mean
faked Rory has the phrase Rob cool bro
cool bro it says it says cool bro ask
somebody would have to be to have that
to portray somebody and put cool ball on
the arm exactly take the costume stop
being out of your costume yeah he has a
dick too there's two dicks also tattooed
on man so he basically he's kind of a
foolish queer like he's got it he's got
dicks and the phrase cool bro and they
the best part is as the morning wears on
he's like realizing the implications of
his costume and I like out of the worst
parts of it but you know what's even you
know what the only thing worse than
doing this is doing it not
you gotta commit to it do it it's on
your arm Troy he came in on yeah you
can't then go like what Rob put it there
yeah so uh so yeah once you give some
some lady advice to hot dog you take her
to a nice restaurant right you take it
down sit her down you talk to her you
have a conversation hot dog it's all
about sex bro get into her head think
about it then we get back you [ __ ]
done
I give him half credit the situation
made no sense by him the tone and the
ending ending worked really well except
through the whole restaurant thing Troy
be like dude you never come over it Troy
would do it quicker and cheaper Troy let
Troy needs to get in there he doesn't
[ __ ] play games to earn a meal with
Troy oh yeah so if she if she maybe
sucks his dick then that's that's a
certain level restaurant go [ __ ] sure
that's another level restaurant for Troy
going to a restaurant with a girl is
like for most people going steady
yeah that's out shopping that's a real
[Laughter]
you wanna go to Samantha in Buffalo
online hello hi hey Samantha
oh it's like the miracle that just keeps
on giving I love it I love him being an
[ __ ] to Troy this is great thank you
Maddy Anthony dress destroyed today but
guess what Anthony sometimes can I tell
you to this day there are people that
hate me for the things that I did as an
intern and as a producer I mean really
like I would not take without one thing
back yeah I think I think whose - who do
you think so many people so many yeah
but your mom is you a talent you see
what that implies right yeah it's harsh
talentless I really you are what have
you brought to the table since you've
started working here seriously Troy I'm
not say it say fight back conspiracies
bro the same you sunset you sound like
Santa Anthony Spears
oh if you just copy what he said like
literally just say the thing that he
just said back to him you have your own
truman capote yeah you could just take
that you could just I could like watch
this watch this okay
bro what have you brought to the table
since you've been here bro
like see how annoying that would be if I
were yeah yeah you know mmm that's good
advice right for the impression oh what
have you brought to the table bro what
have you brought nothing you've done
nothing for the show nothing can't be
afraid when you're on the air you got to
know that like whatever the consequences
are we do the show you go do your [ __ ]
in the office you go home you're gonna
be fine absolutely you ain't worried one
third of the studio and what about
tomorrow do it again tomorrow
duck and cover when you're in here swing
back and go home because what is on the
air is what's gonna last forever
that's right what's back you know off
the air is a little like today to be
hard like who cares
yeah you should come in every day from
here on out as me I would do it
absolutely you kidding me if I found out
that I pissed off somebody as badly as
you're pissing on Troy right now Oh what
I can't understand he would have what
Sam was an intern he did anything I
ain't care the things that I did to
people I did not make it I did not make
a lot of friends Pat Duffy brushed his
teeth with dog [ __ ] yes he did
it was [ __ ] crazy crazy things
happening like I said Sam had Talent
don't worry don't worry about it
Sam knew what he could do sam knew the
power that he had you were just a
useless piece of [ __ ] really you are
useless but he's niko hotdog pointed to
niko and said no that's him
but hotdog niko is portraying Anthony
water you're sitting here and then again
you're not repeating what you're Capote
is saying yeah you're Capote is speaking
and you're just sitting there
shell-shocked lob them back you're on
the air here's the best part do you know
if somebody like Troy said to me I will
never physically touch you I will never
physically harm you I'd be like oh my
god
free rein then doesn't mean not to deal
with me every day here on out doesn't
mean you have to deal with me every day
here on out bro let's let's go to maybe
bill on line three defense yes yeah oh
hello bill hello bill yummy delicious
snuffleupagus snout between his legs I
must refer him to the first ever gay off
yes there it is bill
congratulations you just won a pair of
tickets to see Ricky Gervais sees
humanity tour tomorrow night at the
Dolby Theatre in Hollywood that's right
you are in Los Angeles do not hang up on
him Jim I see that hold on where's the
whole but there it is to the drop button
alright put Bill on hold you're on hold
bill give it all your information to
Travis
Ricky is doing with tomorrow night
tomorrow night at the Dobie and what and
we're also doing is even one more show
yeah there's a San Francisco Seattle and
Vancouver you can visit Ricky Gervais
calm for those dates he snaps pictures
or he'll uh tweet photos of the tours
and like he he has somebody going up to
the back and taking photos he [ __ ]
sells a lot of tickets
he does he does lots of tickets yeah he
did three shows I think total at the
[ __ ] he could have done a full
Madison Square Garden he wanted to yeah
Emily I bet if you if you had somebody
with the right angle it would look like
you sold just as many tickets yeah I
find something with the right Photoshop
ability repeat repeat repeat repeat
what is this chip or chip yeah yes he
can watch more than Jim does that does
that bother you or is it drinks be a joy
you have no good weave wife hated Jim
Norton my whole life to live how about
you let's see I so I'm now somebody
saying that somebody's Adam in
Pittsburgh not a kind word for Troy yes
Adam may ever do in his life he is
trying to stand on the brakes and make
it a little bit of comedy if he possibly
can
I'm not saying what that meant do you
want to repeat that you better phrasing
might be doing the funniest thing you'll
ever do in this life I see a nice it's
really trying its hardest making up no
no it's fine [ __ ] [ __ ] love well that's
fine tell you what's funny it's fine I
know I know I know
it's funny when he when I Q and when
real when big Troy says things like oh
you're bad at your job you're
incompetent bah-bah-bah you had the
[ __ ] printout that says he googled
Google that's when you bring up the
stuff to did that he gets mocked for
that is true he's throwing haymakers and
you're throwing back a little light jams
Ida Troy Adam a real try I don't mean to
help him here but it's like you know
yeah it's obvious stuff you understand
what you know okay you know believe yeah
I've I've had moments where throwing at
my head kicked in in studio oh yeah
they're kind of awesome yeah there's a
couple of weird scary but you're like
we're in it do you understand
you did the world thought that Jesse the
body Ventura was gonna beat up Jim North
and Jericho I ain't nervous on Jericho
yeah yeah first yeah not only did a
retired wrestler almost beat up Jim
Norton an active wrestler almost beat up
Jim Norton yeah those guys because those
guys commit Skerritt but you got to do
it you just you're you're doing it and
you're having your thing and you got a
[ __ ] guard well whatever it is it is
yeah
let's go it's written in Virginia maybe
on line four hello Troy yeah hey you
know it's really disappointing to see
Troy pick on a little [ __ ] look there yo
yellow you gotta get go at it right you
know stick to the conspiracy yeah he's
talking to me what Thanks what do you
say to that [ __ ] loaf I started coming
to my senses
either he lifts the mic down talking
about it the pile of [ __ ] lifting a mic
it says something puts it back I think
it's just hot
you think so mustaches pride perspiring
little dampness on the stache these guys
are like they kind of had no idea what
they were in for yeah but you got a job
maybe never mean it's just Halloween
right what do you mean you hate
Halloween
you look great you cry like it could be
somebody else yeah yeah I mean I know if
I was [ __ ] loaf I wouldn't mind it a day
being Troy oh my god you got it just
good I know that I'd be I'd be [ __ ]
wrecking probably the next six months
but I would still do I wouldn't get six
months yeah more year you gotta do it I
don't care for the decade and yet career
yeah yeah you got to do it it wouldn't
bother me not at all no on the air you
got to do it plus I mean fake Troy you
have to take some sort of joy in the
fact that if Trey is going to bother you
for the rest of your days that means
you've gotten under his skin so bad it's
gonna affect him every day that's
awesome yeah to be so proud so proud of
you yeah yeah you gotta you gotta know
like if a guy if a guy is like you know
kind of in a position where you like are
he's gonna [ __ ] with you or comment on
your work then he's got to know that you
have something in the chamber too so if
you can be him that was always Anthony's
greatest thing with Stern cuz Stern
would say things that Anthony could just
be Howard and Howard and pressure it was
so funny right here when he doesn't say
anything yeah he would just mock Howard
by John Howard he would just say like he
kind of captured something there so
that's what you got to do yeah all right
Dodd now will in New York has a negative
comment hello will yeah I just wanted a
chance of power I really can't stand the
kid his [ __ ] voice is annoying
he lies guys I got through a few weeks
ago and that kid he put me straight
through it oh you want to add something
and he put me right on and the [ __ ]
guy just sucks
I remember this this guy was pointing
out [ __ ] loves inadequacies because he
wasn't screening phone calls he was just
kind of he didn't want to deal with will
in New York so he just put him right on
the air
[ __ ] love what do you say to that he's a
[ __ ] idiot he's a [ __ ] idiot
anymore thank you well thank you goodbye
why does it say Freud is that cool bro
on your arm
Yeah right oh yeah yeah got yesterday
why why'd you get the phrase cool bro
Chaz is cool bro oh I see it's kind of
do you think as an asset asset I Joe Jim
come on
nerdy no is that a dick tattooed on your
arm right here I don't mean to is this a
dick that you had tattooed it were a
dick species bro
you never know you never know you never
know when somebody's gonna cut you a
dick
I'm your arm you don't know we don't
know the whole story yet okay wait come
out you think Jim and I are being part
of the machine maybe I don't know yet oh
no Mike in New Mexico has a suggestion
that's not helpful yes hey guys good
morning
hey Troy oh you don't know hey hey Troy
this one bigs right okay take hot dog
which you're gonna go to [ __ ] Lowe's
house [ __ ] his mother teach that dog how
to [ __ ] real good that does kill Billy
does thank the show god damn it thank
you Mike appreciate real big Troy if you
had the opportunity to have sex with
[ __ ] Louis mom to teach him a lesson we
don't I can't imagine what she looks
like
good luck lady
would bother you if you saw if you came
over and you saw try putting his t-shirt
on in the house how great would it be if
he came home on Halloween and he's still
in his joy costume and he thinks like I
yeah I really showed him and he walks
upstairs and just sees Troy pound than
his mom or if he walked in or he knew
something was going on because Troy was
being a lot nicer to him
and
all the sudden one day his mom he came
home and she had the plastic wrapped
around her forearm oh she got a tattoo
my favorite thing ever the moment that
Anthony walks downstairs and sees Troy
at the breakfast table and kids shirt
goes hey Junior
I've learned Anthony slippers yeah no
shirt no of course not
people are very uh split on this one
yeah yeah that's good maybe ji mind the
jersey yes yeah J what's up buddy
yeah hey guys you know I really like
Troy and I've been with you guys for
more years than I can remember but Papa
Troy is he doesn't think he's only God's
gift to women thinks he's God's gift to
everybody and this was probably the
first time ever in all the years I could
think of where it's been turned around
on him where somebody's making fun of
him or mocking him instead of him
joining in a mocking somebody else Joe
DeRosa Sri Lankan yes yes I didn't work
out did not work out well how my gods
give to everybody how does that make any
sense your attitude what latitude of
what your attitude is you come in
thinking that you know everything I
don't know everything that everybody
appreciates you that everybody likes you
who I'm not finding assets some people
don't like you especially when people
call up and tell you they don't like you
of course people I think in the armor
people like everybody that's on the show
you're gonna get negative comments for
everybody I don't I don't think I'm on a
show I don't know what you like in real
life just shut the [ __ ] up nobody wants
to hear you bro go back to [ __ ]
whatever job you got doing just go bro
we don't need you we don't watch it are
you God's gift [ __ ] you alright James
I'll try once you hung up on so I gotta
hang up on you alright how about this
one
I like it Kevin
hey what's going on yes well shitload oh
you got to remember to build up your
confidence we're dealing with Troy is if
you never have to put on a diaper and
[ __ ] yourself to get a piece of [ __ ]
you one rung on a ladder above him I
don't know Troy [ __ ] himself to get a
piece of [ __ ] I think that he [ __ ]
himself and got a piece of [ __ ] I've
never I've had a lot of [ __ ] in my life
and I've never had to put on a diaper to
get a piece of [ __ ] a pair of jeans or
shorts would work just as well did you
have no you didn't ask them you know
it's a joke shut the [ __ ] up bro all
right whoa all right so are you enjoying
this or are you in one of those things
now where you've done something it's
funny and you kind of come in and you uh
and you come in and let me turn over
turn ya point over turn okay so where we
are yeah we are there that's it does
have the hostile tonality it does yeah
and and then the clipped right right
like I like I like when stuff like this
happens because his arms folded not even
folded properly though he's like he's
gripping his own forearms with his
little hands which is like for the
visual for me for some reason
Nikko is still the MVP of the same just
because it's so yeah he's just sitting
there with any set of goddamn worries
yeah this [ __ ] man I got quiet piece of
[ __ ] just great but I like that lowered
stuff like this happens because it gives
you an insight into the things that
really bother people about other people
you know what I mean like the things
that that Anthony is doing I think are
the things that bother him about Troy
the worst part about it is I don't where
affliction you know I mean yeah we do
we do we wear a couple times I know that
Oh Detroit div soffit on his costume was
great I loved it it's funny trouble bro
trouble
no it's having some fun here oh boy just
goofing right just just joshing around
right don't jump out of character you're
right does he stop being why would I be
mad at Orie has this piece of [ __ ] stop
being a piece of [ __ ] he's been the same
piece of [ __ ] since he walked in this
morning here's James do you think do you
think real Anthony would be mad at Nikko
I'm sure he's not thrilled with the idea
of these portrayed as a pile of [ __ ]
everybody immediately knew we were
supposed to be portrayal accurate
portrayal is a piece of [ __ ]
it took you 40 minutes and we're there
now no you're right I'm sorry sorry yeah
you're right come on
alright alright I do think that there is
an issue when the guy who's technically
in charge of the interns is being
portrayed by the intern with just a
piece of [ __ ] I forgot actually that
he's an intern Anthony's in charge of
them Anthony's boss so it's not a
respectful costume that's not a
respectful portrayal this happened with
our very own Rob and Eric at least like
I don't know at least a pig is like a
living breathing creature like I think
it's worse actually for somebody to be
like oh I put this mask on it's just
[ __ ] like this is why I end all the time
it's a pile of [ __ ] and then I'm not
gonna say anything for the segment I'm
just gonna be a piece of [ __ ]
and everyone's like yeah you're
perfectly portraying your boss right now
it's killing it awesome comment when did
[ __ ] start talking proverbs I think yeah
yeah it's a great bumper sticker yeah I
think I think Sun Tzu said that
when did you decide to dress up like a
piece of [ __ ] we're not just any piece
of [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] loaf right
after you did where'd you find the
costume this party said eat a loaf of
bread what other costume can I mean you
know what he was until just now no I
don't have no idea what the Wonder Bread
was here do you get the he's you now I
get it if I came with what a pound cake
would you have known I tried to avoid
what if I'd to be a break in a pound
[Laughter]
away from that but it probably should
have done he's his mother's you wanted
to bring his mother into it I really
didn't what's everyone looking at me for
bro
Troy you love me right yes the best Melo
mascot loved them where's that piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] loaf right next to you Oh
awful
you don't like [ __ ] well no he's a piece
of [ __ ] why don't you like him
incompetent what do you think is a
[ __ ] incompetent name off the top ten
things the worst things man [ __ ] look
what do you think 10 is a good number
though I mean it's a little it's a
little high but I mean I think that we
let's try me to the top 10 worst
qualities of [ __ ] well Troy [ __ ] that
stupid [ __ ] eating grin he's always got
[ __ ] on oh hold on one second Travis
just tell me to go to somebody sorry
about that uh is he
yep Roland just called which one
Paul well okay the one who you know
start off with all the cameras Travis I
should go to him I mean it's funny yes
he's hello Paul
good morning hi our okay there's our own
pie yeah where are you stuck in the
[ __ ] elevator elevator what floor are
you between and how long he been stuck
I'm at 36th floor and I stuck here for
like four minutes now it won't open
oh I'm in here but how long you been in
there like four minutes
okay four minutes is not bad sometimes
they'll take four or five minutes for
the doors to open are you sometimes it
takes four or five minutes of the doors
to open are you calling for help you're
calling in because I may be stuck in
this elevator for up to ten minutes the
elevator kind of suck yeah they do suck
they suck right they've got people have
gotten stuck I've had them job thank you
that was a major loss Thank You Bobby
happy your life Craig got stuck in the
elevator over at Exim know which Carl
Craig e brah yeah no yeah over at XM we
were at at K Rock Craig was our intern
who ate all the candy on Halloween and
through huh remember yeah and he got
stuck in the elevator on 57th Street and
I went over with the with the camcorder
so I could video the security camera
feed to the elevator so that we could
see it and Craig was in there he was
calling in but he started free cuz it
took it was an old building yeah and it
took way long to get him out he was in
there for like 25 minutes do they have
to do they have to get anybody there do
they have to get like Otis Elevator
people or whatever the [ __ ] it was yep
and he started freaking out in the
elevator started getting claustrophobic
yeah and then he started getting really
hot and he took his shirt off do I
remember crime no no you would remember
I'm sure you would yeah he's the one
that brought no homo to the show right
oh yeah Bobby the champ
okay sorry Bobby I know Bobby there's
been so many guys there's a lot of guys
over the years thank you for I didn't
like it when we were right on his arm no
he wouldn't mean it like that at all
what's that Craig didn't like it because
you get writing on his arms these Jewish
so it's like you're not supposed to mark
his parents get mad cuz his body would
be marked up oh he didn't like that no I
didn't like that Craig no I don't blame
him for would you please you write on it
I only I knew people who would yeah yeah
but I don't think anybody realize like
why until he finally said it
oh then we had to tell everybody to stop
doing that because it's not yeah it's
not a good thing to do it's bad yeah
it's bad that's a good classic yeah who
else is in that one
Bobby the champ Craig I mean
so when you get to it's very good
there's been a lot of guys over the
years and in PT and I forget I meet
somebody and they're like oh my god I
know it's not to be a dick it's not it's
not because I don't remit it's literally
this we've had so many people so why do
you think Troy that of all the interns
that have come through [ __ ] Loaf ended
up getting hired yeah [ __ ] beats me
bro he must have some incriminating
photos of Don or something it's gotta be
I don't know that's the thing you want
to go down that road
that's a fair point what kind of photos
do you think there might be of John
[Laughter]
doing an impression Capote do you just
be you right hmm Don's like hey why'd
you say that about me on the air you be
like it's restraints at lease um shut up
I'm doing my job
[Laughter]
the real Troy a fireman
Chuck in Boston has uh nicosia command
dresser no I think the guys did a good
job I think they both came into the good
job I think yeah yeah you gotta commit
to it though I mean hotdog is committed
to this limp penis costume right right
cannot please a woman outfit at all
right desperate and can't please woman
although I think Nico committed to his
bed well hundred percent of it I I
forgot what it looks like you said that
just a real [ __ ] loaf will be that quiet
that's good okay great like that
actually like dingos outfit you do yeah
I think it's it's it's just where does
it I think it's cute Nico you should I
mean [ __ ] love you should just start
wearing that shirt like as a tease yeah
like hey look at my cool teacher fine
whatever I like it whatever makes you
happy I like that yeah why'd you say
whatever makes you happy what doesn't
make you guys happy
gotta commit because Nico's great except
if there's follow-up questions never
always bad collapses under the weight of
the pressure
well that knee goes right if he's
portraying [ __ ] loaf collapsing under
pressure exactly what you should be
doing it's good yeah so you guys should
be each other for the rest you should be
trying you should be a chef
definitely for the rest of day yeah see
you guys for Troy is giving you his
blessing thank you appreciate it
she does the head things mean just yes
hand raise whatever yeah I wouldn't like
this if it were done about me no none of
us would care for that's what we should
have done right dresses each other and
we should have had them dress as their
interpretation of us we've been ugly
really bad we did that one time wherever
they had to do an impression of
everybody on the show we were in Philly
I remember we all did each other yeah
and we all took it in stride well most
of us did it most yeah not everybody no
well that tends to happen yeah someone
who gets upset feelings get hurt
the UH yeah the food is here do we want
Rob to go get it or do we want no I
would want yeah
actually normally we would send Anthony
but I feel like he needs to be
supervised by Troy yeah I would say the
two of them should go down together yes
so if Anthony and Troy want to go down
and get the food yes [ __ ] loaf and come
on and and Troy since you're a guy who's
like kind of militant you can hear me
I'm talking the way this is why Jim
likes being chip because chip can insult
Jim even though he is Jim [ __ ] loaf is
gonna just become Troy he can insult
wait wait wait till it clicks one day
like oh god this feels right where do
you start outing yourself
make sure Troy since your commit to the
big kind of guy that Nico stays dressed
as [ __ ] love the whole time
done it done cool cool yeah and [ __ ]
love obviously take your love with you
so people otherwise people will be
confused yeah when they said what I wish
you could maybe you give your iPhone you
could shoot him a little bit going down
there and there yeah yeah I think the
elevator was filming a little video well
video never hurt anybody
someone on Twitter is calling him troilo
that's its own security
you wanna Israel you can rob go down and
with them in video yeah of course should
go yeah yeah he should yeah it's
embarrassing after walk down that
costume which well well the Troy one
he's a guy with the people just think
he's a Halloween costume but imagine
walk down the piece of [ __ ] on your head
son you can take that the hat off thing
and his face is so red okay but he's
wearing it down though and the whole
mean he better rob rob will tell us yeah
I just want to take it off for a sec
just to catch a little bit of cool air
yeah
messenger centers every messenger center
this way bro come on pay attention
sighs the way signs
[Applause]
how's the field to be shitload
pretty shitty
[Music]
what are you doing